Did you know that China spends more
on chips than it does on oil? No,
not those chips like microchips, silicon wafers
that are at the center of all electronics and
that make our world go round. These chips, by
the way, are at the center of rising tensions
between the United States and China. This is
economic war. The Biden administration right
now is making it so that American chip makers
can't sell chips to China, forgoing billions of
dollars of revenue. Usually, American presidents
don't want American companies to lose out on a
bunch of money. So what's going on here? Well,
it turns out that a lot of Chinese companies are
buying American microchips and then secretly
using them for like military things. There's
really a blurry line between businesses and the
military in China. Kind of in the United States,
too, TBH. But anyway, all of this has created
a situation where chips are like the new oil,
whoever controls the microchips has
the geopolitical power. This is a big,
deep story. I just made a 30 minute video on it
that explains everything. With lots of beautiful
maps that are like neon colored and a lot of
really good reporting so go check that out.